so we're going to do chess today and
we're going to talk about something very
important
nuclear physics I don't think so we're
going to talk about losing pieces you
guys are losing your pieces and what did
I tell you
don't lose your pieces right okay now
what I like to do is show games and then
show mistakes people make now in the
last class I told them to castle castle
castle
did they castle yeah a little bit
some of them cancelled illegally so they
were trying they moved their King really
far move the rook really far and that
reminded me of chess960 which you never
heard of okay chess960 is when the
pieces are set up sort of randomly on
the back row not the way they are here
and sometimes you Castle really long
although when you're done it looks like
you castled so but sometimes when I see
you guys Castle it's a more suspicious
now if I'm walking around the room which
is unusual because usual just sit but if
I'm walking around the room when I watch
you play chess and I look at your games
I either shake my head like they don't
know how to play chess or I'm like wow
that looks like chess okay so when I
watch a grandmaster game I'm like yeah
those guys are grandmasters and when I
watch guys were rated about 1700 I shake
my head and then when I watch you guys I
cry okay
because when I watch your games
sometimes I move twenty or thirty you
haven't moved a lot of your pieces
you've made like 70 pawn moves it moved
your King about 80 times and your
bishops the Knights haven't moved yet
now watch Grandmaster games I never see
that so I can sort of tell the
difference between your games and
stronger players games if you want to
play better you have to play like a
better player which means get all of
your bishops and nights out and castle
and if I show you games that I played
throughout the last 3040 years I got my
bishops the Knights out and I castled
all of them not once not occasionally
not usually always
so in chess you want to get your bishops
and nights out and castle and I'm going
to show you a game that I played
yesterday in this tournament where I got
all my bishops and nights out and my
opponent tried to prove he can move all
eight of his pawns
he showed me okay then he resigned okay
so in this game which I delete it's I
have to remember it ah
he played Knight f3 now he's winning he
has one piece out and I have zero so did
I give up now okay now I played in the
center and he played in the center and I
got a knight at now it's one to one he
played the Queen's Gambit now most
beginners when they hear the word
Queen's Gambit that's two words they say
oh you're gambling your queen no that's
not the Queen's Gambit that would be a
Queen sacrifice or some of your
sacrifices aren't really intentional now
Queen at Queen's Gambit means your
gammon ting a pawn Queens gambit
accepted Queens gambit declined and the
sloth defense
I played the sloth defense because
that's what I do my opponent played
Knight c3 now he's beating me two to one
two minor pieces out I got one minor
piece out now
I played six this is called the semi
Slav at the Grand Master level this is a
very common position thousands and
thousands and thousands of games now
where did he move this Bishop where did
it go no where is it yeah nowhere right
so did he move his Bishop Knight move
the other Bishop did he go here did he
go in front of his center pawn now he
either went here or here turned out he
went here what says Bishop doing to my
knight the correct answer is what isn't
it doing you yes
I was kidding you can be serious yeah
it's pinning my knight but I moved my
knight anyway because I don't take guff
from anybody okay no I actually I didn't
so if I move my knight he'll take my
queen and then I'll lose then I wouldn't
show you this game then they would have
a meeting at the
a offices to take my Grandmaster title
away they would say hey he gives this
queen up I move for that guy's not so
good so instead of giving my Queen away
I took free material I took this and
this is a very complicated variation
where black wins upon and white gets the
center and white gets development and
white gets everything but black gets
upon so you can argue which is more
important and grandmasters do
grandmasters play e4 in this position
and they want to take this pawn and then
grandmasters go nope you can't have that
pond and then the other Grand Minister
says I'm a Grand Master I'm going to win
your knight you see off the knight moves
you lose your queen so this question is
too hard for my previous class so I
asked this class what is black do to
save material if black doesn't do
anything is going to lose his Knight if
black moves his Knight he's going to
lose his queen so what is black do so he
doesn't lose anything not easy the hands
are up like this much like I don't know
maybe raise your hand up like this okay
and I could make a Ferguson jug what I
won't okay you yes Bishop e7 ton pins
the knight now the knight can move but
it's White's turn so white takes the
knight and black cries we have to avoid
pawn takes an ayat which we can't do so
we need to counter-attack we need to
attack the piece that's pinning us if
only I can see a way to do that
yes
Kwanza age six attacking the bishop the
bishop maintains the pin pawn to g5 it's
asking the bishop again now if the
bishop moves we can move our knight and
just to show you how complicated chess
is white sacrifices a piece black says
thank you and then when White's down to
piece he's going to win this piece for
sure so why it's going to get his piece
back and there's a thousands of
Grandmaster games in this position fact
I've had some of them okay my opponent
didn't do any of that okay that's what
White's supposed to do my opponent was
really worried that I was good that I
was going to mess up the recording my
opponents like don't mess up that's why
what are you talking about so my
opponent was worried I'm going to play
b5 defending my pawn which I would do so
he played a four now if I play b5 he'll
take it and I'll cry notice how he
pinned my knight okay and I was watching
Barney before he was born
what would Barney the Dinosaur do if you
pinned his knight kind of classes this
come on yes break it let's see all that
let me sing I pin you you braked it now
and I never heard that song you I pin
you you Krotz now what would he say very
good I pin you you pin me he's the worst
player in history so I think Barney
would play Bishop to b4 because that
pins his Knight to his King he pinned my
knights and my queen those are different
pins because this knight can move this
knight can move so who's the smartest
this test and knows what the different
names are for those pins yeah
absolute pin absolutely right and the
other one is a relative pin okay
so I'll explain the difference okay if
you go to sub-zero which I'm sure you go
to every day you can have an absolute
pin I mean absolute vodka but you're not
allowed to because you're seven years
old so absolute pin means it's illegal
to have it absolute vodka is illegal
can't have it relative means your
relative like your mom or dad they move
their night away and you take their
queen right so you're playing your
relative you take their queen absolute
is absolutely illegal I can't have that
so absolute pin means it's absolutely
illegal to move a relative pin means you
can move but but don't do it okay
so my opponent made a bad move he should
play in the center get his bishops and
nights out and castle those are the
three things you want to do in the
opening he didn't do any of those
he played rook to c1 okay that's not
doing any of the stuff I said now I want
to be a pawn ahead and he wants to take
my pawn I played b5 notice there's two
white pieces attacking b5 and there's
only one black piece defending b5 so why
doesn't mine move lose upon how come is
in two more than one yeah
the knight is pinned so if he tries to
take with a knight the computer won't
let them because it's pinned so my move
is safe okay
so I'm doing Wow now should you move the
same piece every move
well maybe the inserts of now if I'm
asking you but if you're playing me then
yes because I want to win right okay if
you move the same piece every move
you're going to lose because your other
pieces aren't moving well he moved the
same piece again
now his Knights on my pawn so I
protected my pawn with my bishop also my
bishop didn't move yet okay now made
another strange move pawn here okay I
don't know what that was all about I got
my night out hooray for me now I'm in
another strange move Queen here I'm not
sure what those moves have to do with
castling and getting your bishops and
nights out I must have missed something
okay so now my Knights pinned remember
how it was pinned we had that discussion
when your Knights pinned you don't want
it pinned because then you can't move so
there's two things you can do you can
unpin let's say Bishop here for example
that my I could move or just move your
queen out of the way so it's not pinned
now I'm not pinned yay and I'm attacking
his pawn and I'm defending my pond
okay so he took he took he took my
knight who likes to vote okay you could
vote for three things here King takes
knight Knight takes Knight or pap you
cannon those are the three things you
can vote for who votes for King takes a
knight
what's worse than king takes Knight Pat
Buchanan so it has to be Knight takes
Knight
okay so Knight takes Knight is what I
did I don't want to move my king in the
middle and he protected his pawn with
the move III now I should I take his
pawn anyway to show you no no okay
so I wanted to play c5 and attack his
pawn but this pawn isn't protected as
much so I protected it more and then I
won the game of tic-tac-toe but we were
playing chess now my opponent should get
his Bishop out and castle that's what
you would do right or would you move a
pawn on the side for no reason also a
good idea
my opponent moved a pawn on this side
for no reason okay so I castled and he
was like all right I'll Castle too and I
was like well before you castle let me
go take that pawn now I'm going to take
this pawn and he was like no well he did
that I didn't know he did that he did
pawn takes pawn and I took with a night
and he castled finally okay now I
attacked his Bishop but he didn't want
me to take it I wanted to take it so he
moved it to a safe square Bishop f4 and
I attacked his rook what's worth more a
knight or a ruck a rook so he moved his
rook now I made the losing move I played
Queen takes pawn shack he didn't see
Bishop takes Queen so then I took his
Bishop is that what happened no no
that's what happened in your games
you take this I'll be like what they go
here like ah that's better
okay so instead I attacked his pawn with
another piece how did I attack this pawn
with another piece how did I do it
magic actually it was magic how do i
attack III with something else all the
way in the back
I guess that's right because he was
clapping for your answer
Bishop to c5 okay then he traded pawns
and then he was like how do I defend
this the answer is you can't but he did
anyway okay if I was white I would play
King claw if I was white I'd be like why
am i white here okay I would play King
h1 but he defended his pawn notice Queen
d3 loses the Queen Queen d2 loses the
Queen Queen c1 loses the Queen rook g3
loses the rook there's really no way to
defend that pawn plea defend it anyway
King f2 that's not really why he castled
but okay you wanted to defend his point
now in chess sometimes you want to take
stuff you always want to take stuff but
it's protected so you don't take it well
I wouldn't one thing you could do is
find the piece that's protecting it and
make that piece move away
that's called removing the defender well
I can't make this guy move away but I
can make this guy move away okay that
guy is getting scared
look he's yellow I can make that guy
move away what move can black make to
attack that bishop and make him move
away it looks like we have a calling
voter let's see yes
Bishop to d6 would make you move away
except our Bishop is the one that's
attacking the pawn also there's a rook
here yeah but yeah but there's a rook
here so that would be risky and if you
if he takes the bishop you still can't
take this because there's a king
defending so Bishop d6 is risky it might
work but it might not how else can we
attack that Bishop what else can black
do yes I could play g5 but he's got a
lot of guys on that he could take that
he could take again and he's still on my
pawn here he's still defending his pawn
also g5 makes my king a little shady yes
Bishop to e5 this Bishop to e5 or this
one pawn to e5 that's what I did right
okay now if his bishop moves away I'll
take his e3 pawn if his bishop doesn't
move away I'll take his bishop he
decided a bishop was worth more than a
pawn so he took and I took now did he
play King takes bishop like half of you
would now because he can't right so he
can play king e1 I don't think that's
why he castled or you could play King g3
they're both terrible - terrible moves
you got any one of them he made the
better one according to the computer
King to g3 now you may have noticed in
your own chess games that rooks move up
and down in sideways and you may have
also noticed when you have a pawn in
front of your rook your rook can't move
okay for example my rook on f8 it can't
move up and down because I have a pawn
in front of it
therefore you may have heard the phrase
rooks go on open files rooks go on files
with no pawns
so this rook and this rook are on files
the other chu
books are sort of blocked by pawns so I
played rook to e8 attacking his bishop
and he should either move his bishop or
protect his bishop but he made a bad
move he attacked my queen
okay and if I take his Rock he'll take
my queen and if I take his bishop he'll
take my queen but when I move my queen
now he has a couple of issues bishops
attacked twice and his vicious
protecting his rook so for example if he
saves his bishop and his rook I could
remove the defender and then take his
rook he can he be in a lot of trouble
then so how can he save his rook and his
bishop what did he do he made the only
move to save them both yes this time say
pawn yeah pawn f4 that's what he did
right now everything's protecting
everything okay
Kings protect every okay and I won
tic-tac-toe earlier but now he wouldn't
connect for so luckily it was a chess
game so he didn't have much chance again
I actually played in a bridge tournament
last night I'm sure all you 10 11 year
old kids play bridge and and I told the
guy he said how guru abridged I said
well I'm a grandmaster just not a bridge
I said but if a chess tournament breaks
out we're all set okay
unfortunately chess tournament did not
break out okay so one rule that I tell
all my students and I'll even tell you
is you should take all of your
opponent's pieces right so guess what I
did in this position I took all of his
pieces following my own advice okay
they're all on the same diagonal so I
took this one what do you think he did
he took with the pawn and then I checked
his King and attacked his rook I thought
taking all his pieces was a good idea he
got out of check and I took his rook
where I play Queen d5 was in turn 18 I
would have lost the mouse slip okay
now if I was playing another Grandmaster
they would give up here because they're
incredibly lost that I would question
why they played so badly but all right
now this guy he's not a grandmaster so
he's like yeah I've been down a piece
before I'm always down a piece no
problem so he took this pawn attacking
my queen now my last class they didn't
do this so well maybe you guys will do
better okay then we have a bet on it so
to a good job okay
this Knight and this King you know
they're pretty out in the open black has
a move that attacks both of them true
story what move is it in the corner e5
that attacks the knight but it doesn't
attack the king but the claws f5 would
do it but that 5zi illegal and hangs the
Queen how do we attack the knight and
the King at the same time and is that
called a spoon or a knife for or as my
kids said last class it's called a pin
well that's what he said you Queen d7
Shak attacking his King and his knight
now actually he can save his King and
his Knight but he didn't do it if he
does do it it's worse than what he did
so it's good he didn't do it for him how
does he say this King and his Knight yes
Queen f5 now I can play the simple Queen
takes Queen rook takes Queen Bishop c8
pinning his rook to his King but my
chess engine says I should play Bishop
c8 right away even stronger and the idea
is if you take I'm still forking your
King at night you still can't even avoid
that okay so he didn't play Queen f5
he played King h2 saving his King and I
said yum-yum-yum-yum-yum okay now blacks
up to pieces and when two grandmasters
play it's very rare to see somebody up
two pieces because the other guy usually
gave up by then okay but this guy keeps
going Bishop takes pawn forking my
knight and my queen how did I save them
both I don't want to lose my knight or
like Queen I like my knight in my queen
yes counter did I do what move Knight d4
well as Groucho Marx once said and you
bet your life or what's my line or
something that answer is better than
mine yeah 94 actually would be a fine
move I don't see anything wrong with it
looks good I did something else but you
found it move it's just as good as my
move yeah well Queen a4 I'd still lose
my knight it's attacked twice I play
Queen e5 check or f5 losing my queen one
of them Queen e5 check attacking his
king so he can't take my knight say he
blocked the check and I saved my night I
tried to anyone now I'm up to pieces and
I'm forking to pieces
hooray he played Bishop takes pawn check
did I take his rook and make it double
check if I had no notation sheet I could
double check now I play King age shake
because that's allowed thought it was
allowed and he played rook F 5 attacking
my queen
most of you would play Queen take struck
your opponent to play queen takes me to
go ah I hate when that happens
okay so I didn't do that because I hate
when that happens
now here black is up to pieces that's
good and blacks whites king is very
suspicious so one thing I thought about
doing I didn't do it though was rook a
one and if he takes my queen
then checkmate I thought about doing
that but that I don't want to get too
fancy okay because you know I don't
really like that song anyway I played
Bishop g1 check that's as fancy as I get
now my opponent did something you'll
never never never ever never ever do
ever what did he do you guys might he
resigned he gave up okay you guys
shouldn't do that now if he takes my
bishop Black has checkmate in one move
if you're taking notes checkmate in one
move is good how does black checkmate
white in one move yes Queen takes g3
checkmate hashtag checkmate the Queen's
attacking the King the bishop is
defending h1 the Knights defending f1
and obviously the black Queens defending
all that with so many colors what chance
does he have so he saw that so he
doesn't like that so he could have
played King h3 that's what I expected
then I was going to play Queen e2
threatening Queen G to check and
threatening Bishop g2 check I guess
that's mate and threatening Bishop c8
pinning his rook and I'm up to pieces so
he decided resigning was a good idea
okay he must have learned it from Nixon
right nothing yeah nothing in there no
all right and that's funny because I
just taught a chess camp at the Gerald
Ford Presidential Library in Arbor
I'm telling the kids never to resign but
I'm in a building because the president
resigned sodden it was very strange
situation for me right you agree now
nothing you got nothing no okay well you
tried okay so that was a game that I
played yesterday now unfortunately I
wanted to show you another game that I
played but that game yeah I forgot it
but that game was a hundred and six
moves okay and the last time I said 106
move game everybody started crying
including me okay and the people at home
they were in tears they're like a
hundred and six moves show us something
that was like five moves long what's
wrong with you okay so my hundred and
the sixth move game ended in a draw but
we had a good excuse it was King versus
King and he had the opposition so King
versus King that was it so we agreed to
a draw is that fair I that's a good idea
we couldn't win King versus King nothing
we could do again we tried hard though
that game went five hours just like most
of your games that game I just showed
you that game what about an hour that's
that's fair then I have a lot of
half-point byes where I don't play so I
can teach you guys so I don't play very
often but when I do play I either win an
hour or I draw in five hours it's
unclear which is better I think winning
is better okay now I'll show you another
game but I'll let you guys decide do you
want to see one of my great games or do
you want to see a great game in chess
history by somebody else who says my
game yes well I actually got a lot of
votes who says a great game in history
wow it was close I think what do you
think I think mighty game one yeah yeah
okay we could do a count but we don't
have a quorum it's terrible okay so we
look at one of my games let's see should
we do one from the last two years or
from 1989
1989 I agree now there's a chance for
you never heard of called Boris Gelfand
right he's he's the highest rated player
in Israel he's originally from Belarus
but he moved to Israel and two years ago
he played for the World Chess
Championship with the person who was the
world chess champion who was the world
champion two years ago me right yes
Anand Anand gelfand
and whoever wins that match was the
world champion and the match was tied
six to six nobody won
then they had a playoff like blitz chess
or something and a non one so none was
the world champion then you never heard
a golf fan because he did win the match
and Anand then lost his match to whom
the next year yes Magnus Carlsen and in
two months who was an on going to lose
to again say the answer yeah Magnus
Carlsen they're going to play again in
November okay not good for a non okay
and then that'll be the end of an on
because then he'll retire at some point
probably after the match okay and then
Carlos will be world champion forever
right now if you want to see Magnus
Carlsen in person what what are you
going to do yes what would you do go to
the sing field cup where's that being
held somewhere in Australia where here
in this chess club so Magnus Carlsen
will be here in nine days that you can
see them the hey that's Magnus Carlsen
also other grandmasters will be here who
are much better than me but they won't
be lecturing to you they'll be winning
hundreds of thousands of being their
opponents okay Singh field cup has six
of the top 10 players in the world
it's the highest rated chess tournament
of all time plus tax yes your go are you
playing now okay
what I agree that's what I'm going to do
also food at Lester's okay so this is a
game I played in 1989 possibly 1990 who
can remember okay and I was white and we
played your favorite opening the
nimzo-indian notice how his bishop is
pinning my knight is that an absolute
pin or relative pen absolutely right and
I played Queen c2 that's my favorite
variation defending my knight yeah he
played c5 attacking my pawn but I didn't
see it so I gave up no wait a minute I
took it
hooray now he made a strange move Queen
c7 so I guess he wanted me to not play
Bishop f4 if I thought this would before
I think I know what he would do so I
played Knight f3
I played Bishop to g5 I moved this
Bishop where I move this Bishop now I
played III and then I move my Bishop now
where'd he move this Bishop alright so
he played this castle hey I got all my
bishops at night side and Castle amazing
okay and he played here and now if you
remember the last game which was about
four minutes ago I said rooks like to go
on open files so I put my rooks on open
files and there's only one open file so
I put both tricks on it and now an
important decision was made the decision
to lose the game luckily made by my
opponent not by me okay here black has
two ways to castle the correct way and
the way that lets me win the game he was
a very nice opponent now I have to
explain this move golf fan is a much
better player than I am so he wants to
win he's like been Feingold
a free point he was Elektro me at the
mouth it's anyway he said if the game's
really boring and it's a draw that would
be a tragedy I have to make the game
really complicated and then my opponent
will blunder every move and I'll win
that's what he was thinking
so instead of playing the boring move
castles which computer will say is an
equal position he castled the long way
now when you Castle you're supposed to
have a safe king with pawns in front of
it
whoever black moved all of his pawns on
the Queen side I don't think that was a
good idea now there's a name for this
kind of position other than winning for
white it's called opposite side castling
I Castle one way he castles the other
way usually in those positions
there's pawn storms okay sort of like
last night there were storms right did
you sell the pawns coming down okay how
do you think these sets get here so I
pawn storm his king and he tries to pawn
store my King and I attacked his pawn
notice how all my guys are attacking his
pawn so he played he 5 and he continued
with the pawn storm and I could see with
my pawn store and he put his rook over
here so he's going to meet me and I'm
going to meet him okay and even though I
was successful he became one of the top
five players in the world and I'm one of
the top five players on my block okay I
don't think there's four players on my
block better than me okay so I busted
through a five he was like thank you and
then c5 then he was like wait a minute
this guy's busting through on the
queenside he's going to checkmate me he
didn't like that in fact if he had taken
my pawn I would have played b5 and then
if he had taken that pawn I would have
taken with a night and he would have
cried a lot because boy am I going to
checkmate him now I'm attacking his
Queen I have two pieces attacking his e5
pawn my rooks are doubled my queen is
here on his King and his King has almost
nothing in front of it anymore
if he plays queen c6 I would win his
queen with a fork okay so he doesn't
like any of that so he attacked me g4
and then I forked his Queen and Bishop
and then everybody took everything
that's fair right
all we did was take stuff okay now
you'll notice my Knights attacked
because my Knights attacked however my
Knight isn't a relative pin if I move my
knight it'll play Queen takes Queen and
I'll lose and then I'm not showing you
this game okay so I can't move my knight
but if I don't move my knight he'll take
it okay but his king is pretty open so I
checked him now the game got very
interesting for me if he plays Queen b8
you guys know what to do right okay he
plays 9 b8 well he did play 98 so look
at that later King to b7 that's the
interesting move because now I can win
his queen for Grandmaster pretty easy
for you guys I don't know it takes 3
moves but white can win black's queen
and he saw it and I saw it the question
is do you see it
how does white win black's queen first
you do a skewer and then you do a fork
okay and then you go to the Greek
restaurant because you're already know
nothing there's only one skewer that I
see yeah
rook to a7 is a skewer we're attacking
the king and the Queen I think black
should take that rook otherwise I'm
going to take his queen right and now I
have a fork because his king and queen
are lined up just so Wesley so would
approve boy now the hands go out they're
like wait a minute
bathrooms over there yes anyone yeah all
right I like to dance
what's the answer ix b5 check and I win
his queen anyway he didn't like that
because he liked his queen so he played
9 to b8 now you remember my knight can't
move because it's pinned now in the
previous game which you forgot there was
a position where I'm going to take this
with me oh I guess I'm going to take it
with me man they were right you can't
take it with you all right there was a
position where my queen was here and my
knight was here and his bishop was here
attacking them and I played Queen e5
check that was in the last game this
game I have a similar motif my knight
can't move because I lose my queen but I
moved my queen away with Czech bathroom
still over there ok how did I move my
Queen way with Shaq yes
possibly this square check now my nights
nap pinned also he's in check
also his Knights attacked also he's
checkmated ok so now he resigned he gave
up he can't move his King here or here
it's illegal
he was his Queen here my rook will take
it if he plays King here I do the exact
same thing we just looked at Rick a7
Shak and 9b v Chuck so the only move
that makes any sense is Knight here and
all of his Knights are pinned then I was
going to play Bishop takes pawn Queen
takes bishop
checkmate that was my plan most of you
don't think it's checkmate yet well let
it sink in has it sunk in yet see his
Knights pinned and my rooks defending my
queen that's checkmate and if he moves
this Queen away let's say here now
do you like sacrifice your queen er you
don't now ok if you don't then you play
rook takes Knight check and then
checkmate if you like sacrificing your
Queen you play Queen takes Knight check
and then checkmate so since everything
was checkmate he decided getting made it
wasn't the best idea so he gave up and
in this position my computer says white
is up plus 12 that would be like being
ahead of Queen Anne deny it
so he didn't like that although
computers then probably said it was
equal because it was 89 so the next time
we have a lecture we're going to get
some way from the audience they're going
to show us a game they played several
years ago for memory you guys gets off
to be ready for that
ok that's the next time you agree now
see he agrees so that's it I can't I
can't take that back
ok so that was one of my favorite games
because that guy went on to become one
of the top players in the world I have
another game that I like to show except
I haven't memorized it so I don't show
it and that's my game with your favorite
player the number 3 player in the world
he's American
but he plays for Italy who's that he's
number three in the world yeah
what do you think his name is no ideas
correct
another answer would be Fabiano Cara
Juana and he'll be here for the
Sinquefield Cup in about nine months ago
I was in London and I saw him at a
tournament and I said hey we played a
million years ago he goes oh yeah you
won didn't you and I was like yeah he's
like yeah okay and now he's number three
in the world and again I wanted the top
three on my block
you